Where we ended with last Wednesday was
the tail end of our discussion of the
Anti enlightenment.
And I think some of you discussed in
section the difficulties that arise when
you think about the complete rejection
of the enlightenment project.
For instance,
I think a very dramatic example that
fixes our intuition's very quickly,
um, is the, is the example that
I know some of you discussed,
which is that in the 1950s
in the United States,
there was no such thing as marital rape.
We can remember this from
our discussion of male. Um,
the wife was the channel of the husband
and her legal identity was suspended,
uh,
for the course of the marriage.
And she was not only could a husband
not be prosecuted for raping his wife,
he could not be prosecuted for assault.
You could not be prosecuted for doing
all kinds of things to her that if he did
it to some on unrelated
person on the street, uh,
would land him in jail or worse.
Um,
now if you think about Macintyre's
discussion of practices in the 1950s,
this was an accepted norm
of the prevailing practice.
And the argument that this should be seen
as unjust or unacceptable wouldn't get
any purchase from an ethic that
was based on the idea that,
um,
we missed except inherited
conditions and norms and practices.
And so, um, the,
the one important takeaway point
from that is however difficult the
enlightenment ideas of individual
rights and trying to make, um,
objective statements about what goes on
within systems of Human Association is
however difficult that enlightenment
project is giving up on a completely
presents even more in Superbowl problems
because very few people are really
going to want to go all the way with
abandoning the idea that the individual
should be subordinated to community
norms and practices and abandoning the
notion that we can appeal
only to tradition in, um,
thinking about,
um,
whether or not conditions as we've
inherited them are acceptable and so
entered democracy.
The last section of the course in which
we're going to talk about a tradition
which I think does a better job than
any that we have considered here.
The two,
in delivering on the promise
of the mature enlightenment,
the promise to recognize individual
rights as the most important normative,
ideal and to base politics on
some commitment to objective
knowledge about human
society. Um, that goes beyond the,
um,
beliefs,
commitments and practices of whoever
happens to be around and whatever values
they happen to have.
Now,
one thing about democracy
that distinguishes it from
all of the traditions we've
considered thus far is that it's a
tradition that was made famous by it's
critics. If you think about the
ones we've considered thus far,
you know,
the social contract was made
famous by Hobbes and Locke.
A utilitarianism was
made famous by Bentham.
Marxism obviously made famous by marks.
These will all,
um,
the,
these were all ways of looking at the
world that had their champions and it was
the champions that made the case for
why we should behave in accordance with
their dictates. And with the
inland anti enlightenment as well,
it was Burke as the big champion
of the Anti Enlightenment.
And then we looked at some modern
anti enlightenment thinkers.
Democracy was made famous by it's critics.
Who Do you think this is? Any
guesses? Who is that on the left?
That Jen on the left.
Nobody now nobody wanted get who's that?
Yeah.
Close. Huh? Okay.
Who is the [inaudible] the right.
Anyone the first one to get it
gets a free book. Yeah, you got it.
Come and see me later. You'll
get your free book. Um,
okay.
These are both people who were
not champions of democracy.
MMM.
They were worried about
the potential that
democracy has four tyranny.
Let's listen to Plato.
I don't know if you can read that,
but I'll read it to you and
don't try and write it down.
I will put it up on the uh,
server.
Plato has two very famous
analogies in the, in the republic,
which sum up his appalling
disdain for democracy.
He says,
imagine then a fleet or a ship in which
there is a captain who is taller and
stronger than any of the crew,
but he is a little deaf and has a similar
infirmity insight and his knowledge of
navigation is not much better.
Kind of dopey old captain.
The sailors are quarreling with
one another about the steering.
Everyone is of the opinion
that he has the right to steer.
Though he has never learned the art of
navigation and cannot tell who taught him
or when he learned and will further
assert that a cat that it cannot be toward
and that they are all ready to cut to
pieces. Anyone who says the contrary,
they throng about the captain begging and
praying him to commit the helm to them.
And if at any time they do not prevail
but others are preferred to them,
they kill the others with
throw them overboard.
And having first chained up the Nobels
captain senses with drink or some
narcotic drug,
they mutiny and take possession of the
ship and make free with the stores.
Thus eating and drinking.
They proceed on their voyage in such
a manner as might be expected of them.
Him who is their partisan and cleverly
aids them in their plot for getting the
ship out of the captain's
hands and into their own, uh,
whether by force or persuasion,
they compliment with
the name of Salem pilot,
able seaman and abused the other sort
of man with whom they call a good,
whom they call a good for nothing,
but that the true pilot must pay attention
to the year and the seasons and the
sky and the stars and the wind and
whatever else belongs to his art.
If he intends to be really
qualified to command a shit.
Now in vessels which are in a state of
now in vessels which are in a state of
mutiny and by sailors who are mutineers,
how will a true pilot be regarded Willie
and not be called by them a pray to a
star gazer or a good for nothing.
And then Plato's other famous analogy
which looks at the masses rather than uh,
how they will manipulate the government.
He says,
suppose a man was in charge of a large
and powerful animal and made a study of
its moods.
And once he would learn when to approach
it and handle it when and Wyatt was
especially savage or gentle,
what the different noises it made
meant and what the tone of voice,
what tone of voice to to use
to sue that or to annoy it.
All those he might learn
by long experience and
familiarity and then call it a
science and reduce it to a
system and set up to teach it.
But he would not really know what the,
which of the chicest tastes and
desires was admirable or shameful,
good or bad,
right or wrong.
He would simply use the terms
on the basis of its reactions,
calling what it pleased good and what
place did go ahead and what annoyed it
bad. So Plato didn't have
much regard for democracy.
Not surprisingly because in three 99 BC,
it,
the democracy in Athens at executed
his hero and teach us Socrates,
um,
precisely for pointing out the sorts of
lack of knowledge that he is alluding to
here,
both in the ship's captain analogy
and I'm playing to the mob sentiments,
um, that he's alluding
to with the, um, this,
this analogy of the power of the people
in a democratic system as being a
powerful animal.
And so Plato was very unimpressed with
democracy as a potential system of rural.
He thought it would quickly
collapse into charity.
The phrase that tyranny of the majority
though was made popular by Alexis de
Tocqueville.
You've already run into this.
When we talked about
mill's harm principle. Um,
Tocqueville was a 19th
century French aristocrat who,
who went to America to try and understand
how American democracy work because it
seemed to him less destructive of
freedom and individual liberties.
Then what was coming
down the pike in Europe,
he thought the French aristocracy and,
and the French monarchy was way too short
sighted in not seeing that they have
to understand the egalitarian trends
of modern history and to create
institutions that could lose sue them
and control them and domesticate them.
So people think of Tocqueville often is
a great defender of democracy and in a
certain sense he was.
But he was also a critic of democracy.
And I'll go into that a little
bit more detail shortly. Um, but,
but his main reason for thinking that
American democracy was a relatively good
system was its propensity to
limit egalitarian impulses,
uh, that he thought were
breaking out all over Europe.
And so Tocqueville's summation of his
fear of the tyranny of the majority comes,
um, in, in a democracy
in America. He says,
when I see that the right and the means
of absolute control are conferred on any
power, whatever, be it
called a people or a king,
an aristocracy or democracy,
a monarchy or a republic.
I say there is the germ of tyranny
and I s and I seek to live elsewhere.
And to other lawyers.
In my opinion,
the main eval of the present
democratic institutions.
The United States does not arise as
it's often asserted in Europe from their
weakness,
but from the irresistible strength.
I am not so much alarmed at the excessive
liberty which rains in that country as
as in the inadequate securities,
which one finds their against tyranny
and individual or a party is wronged in
the United States.
If an individual or a party has
wronged in the United States,
to whom can he apply for redress?
If to public opinion,
public opinion constitutes the
majority if to the legislature.
It represents the majority
and implicitly obeys it.
If the executive power it is appointed
by the majority and serves as a passive
tool in its hands.
The public force consists
of the majority on the arms.
The jury is the majority invested with
the right of hearing judicial cases and
in certain states, even the judges
are elected by the majority.
However, iniquitous or absurd,
the measure of which you complain,
you must submit to it as well as you can.
So democracy brings with it this
problem of the tyranny of the majority.
And it was after all we saw earlier in
this course against that that John Stuart
mill erected his harm principle.
He too had this great fear
of tyranny of the majority.
And so as I said,
democracy was made famous
first by it's critics.
And they point out that it
has this propensity to panda
to mass opinion without
regard to whether it's true or false and
to ride roughshod over the individual
rights,
uh,
again without regard to whether
this produces a domination or worse.
Um,
so that being the case,
it seems like prime of facie and not
very encouraging to think that democracy
can deliver on the enlightenment where
we talking about politics that's based on
science and politics
that respect individual rights.
And so you might given reading
mail as you have given what I,
the little bit of Plato and Russo that
I've just shown to you and your own
thinking about, um, politics.
As you confront it day today,
you might well be skeptical of the
proposition that democracy is going to
deliver very well on the
mature enlightenment.
And so just how that might be the case
is what's going to concern us for this.
And then the next three lectures,
and we're going to start out consideration
of democracy with the federalist
papers.
The federalist papers are
probably along with roles,
the two most important pieces of political
theory ever to come out of America.
Um,
they were a series of articles published
in the newspapers of New York state,
as I'm sure most of you know,
uh,
in order to try and help get
the constitution ratified.
They were,
although Orthod by these three gentlemen,
James Madison Alexandre Habel Ah,
how Hamilton and John Jay,
they were signed by the night
with the pseudonym Publius,
which was short for poor bliss,
hilarious public Carla,
who was reputed to be the console who had
restored the Roman Republic in five Oh
nine BC,
whether in fact it is a at
that's debated by historians.
Um,
the constitution,
by the time they wrote these,
the vast majority of these papers,
these letters to the people of New
York had already been approved by the
majority of the 13 states if bought.
Um,
few people believe that it
would survive if it wasn't, uh,
um, adopted in New York. Uh, the,
the confederate
constitution it provide had,
had required unanimity for the
adoption of the constitution.
But in the, the actual constitution
itself, they had said, well,
nine out of the 13 states will be enough,
but nobody really thought it could
survive if it was not adopted in New York.
And so the federalists
took upon themselves
the task, um, Hamilton,
Madison and Jay up persuading the p
the people of New York to support the
adoption of the constitution.
And indeed they were
successful in that endeavor.
Yeah.
But they had the fear of this problem
of majority tyranny that I've already
alluded to with respect to Plato and,
um,
male and Tocqueville front
and in their considerations.
And [inaudible]
two shouldn't be surprised that they
would worry about that because if you
imagine yourself back
into the 18th century,
thinking about democracy.
Okay.
The ancient ideal of democracy,
the ancient Athenian ideal of democracy
had basically been the notion of ruling
and being ruled in term.
So,
you know, if you have an
academic department, let's say,
let's set aside the problem, the
issue of, of untenured faculty.
Just imagine a a department
of tenured faculty,
we have a circulating chair, right?
Somebody chair for three years,
then somebody else,
then somebody else.
That's the notion of ruling
and being ruled in turn.
And the reason you can do that is
that everybody basically has the same
interest.
Okay?
You don't have to worry about monitoring
or controlling the current ruler
because basically they have the
same interest as you do. Um,
and they're not therefore going to do
anything with the collective that you
wouldn't do yourself.
So that's the ancient ideal of
democracy is ruling and being ruled.
In turn it, it obviously in
the case of ancient Greece,
it excluded women at
excluded slaves. So, um,
it was, uh, a certain, uh,
truncated conception of a democratic
community about which people of discourse
that great length.
But given that the model was the idea
that you could have a ruling and being
ruled in turn without loss because
everyone was assumed basically to have the
same interests.
Now,
as soon as you get a
diversity of interests,
that
mechanism of government goes off
the table as a way of doing things.
Because then you might have subgroups
who see that let's suppose you introduce
nontenured faculty,
they're going to have a very different
interest than the tenured faculty.
And so the idea of ruling
and being ruled in turn, uh,
wouldn't work anymore. Once you have
a serious division of interest within,
within the polity,
you have this problem.
And this is the problem Madison
articulates in federalist
number 10 when he says
by a faction,
I understand a number of citizens,
whether amounting to a majority or a
minority of the hall who are United and
actuated by some common impulse of passion
or interest adverse to the rights of
other citizens or to the permanent and
aggregate interests of the community.
So once you have factions,
you have this problem,
right?
If you're the majority faction,
it doesn't matter to you,
but it does if you're the minority
faction because things are gonna happen
you don't like.
So the first thing Madison says to himself
is, what could we get rid of factions?
And, and if you read
federalist number 10 carefully,
you will see that he thinks that the,
the costs of doing that would be so great
in terms of lost human freedom and the
kind of repression you would
have to engage in. Uh, you know,
it would look like the French
revolution or the Russian revolution,
which of course he didn't
know about, but which, uh,
he didn't know about
either of those things,
but he wouldn't have
been surprised by them.
Uh, when, uh,
he wrote this,
so you can't get rid of factions.
The causes of factions can't be removed
and therefore you have to look at their
effects.
He says the Leighton causes of
faction or sewn in the nature of man,
and we see them everywhere brought into
different degrees of activity according
to the different circumstances
of civil society.
So strong is this propensity of mankind
to fall into mutual animosities that
were no substantial
occasion presents itself.
The most frivolous and
fanciful distinctions have
been sufficient to kindle the
unfriendly passions and excite the most
violent conflicts by the most common and
durable source of.
But the most common and durable sorts
of factions has been the various unequal
distribution of property.
Those who hold and those who are without
property have formed distinct interests
in society.
Those who are credit is,
and those who are dead is fall
under like discrimination, uh,
landed interest,
a manufacturing interest and merch until
interest and moneyed interest with many
lessons,
interest grow up off necessity in
civilized nations and divide them into
different classes,
actuated by different sentiments in views.
The regulation of these various and
interfering interests forms the principal
task of modern legislation and involves
the spirit of party and faction in the
necessary an ordinary operations of
government managing factions so that they
don't destroy the common interest
is the basic business of politics.
Now,
how do you do that?
Well,
how do you manage
the effects of faction?
He goes on and he says,
the smaller the society,
the fewer probably will be the distinct
parties and interest composing it.
The fewer the distinct parties
and interest. The more frequently,
well a majority be found of the same
party and the smaller the number of
individuals composing a majority and the
smaller the compass within which they
are placed the more easily we'll they
concert and execute their plans of
oppression.
Oops,
extend the sphere and you take in a
greater variety of parties and interests.
You make it less probable that a majority
of the hall we'll have a common motive
to invade the rights of other citizens.
Or if such a common motive exists,
it will be more difficult
for all who feel of it.
Feel it to discover their own strength
and to act in unison with each other.
Besides other impediments,
it may be remarked that where there is a
consciousness of unjust or dishonorable
purposes,
communication is always checked
by distrust in proportion
of the number who's a
concurrence is necessary.
Hence it clearly appears that the same
advantage which a republic has over a
democracy and controlling the effects
of faction is enjoyed by a large over a
small republic.
Isn't is enjoyed by the Union
of the States Union over
the states comprising it.
I will talk in a little while about what
advantages Madison thinks a republic
has over a democracy.
But right now I want to focus on his
this other point which is that a large
republic has an advantage
over a small republic.
It's society had that has no factions
at all presents no problems for four
democratic theory as we've already talked
about in connection with the stylized
idea of ancient Greece as one in which
everybody has the same interests and you
can have rules and being ruled in turn
ruling and being ruled in turn what
Madison is most afraid off is a single
faction I majority faction because if you
have a society in which um,
there's a majority that agrees all the
time or most of the time the problem is
what about these people
that are going to be
okay
on the losing end.
So if you have a society in which race
and class and religion all tend to fall
along the same division,
okay,
these people are either going to be
have to knuckle down to tyranny,
right?
Or they're going to reach
where they had guns.
They'll overthrow the system if they can.
And if they cannot,
they might as well become criminals,
right?
They're not going to have an incentive
to participate in the democratic order.
And so from Madison's point of view,
this is the ideal society.
You know, we think, you know,
modern Polen 99% Catholic
or something like that. Um,
but even there that there are other
divisions. So even there it doesn't work.
But if you're going to have factions,
the worst thing to have
is one or a small number.
What you really want is lots of factions,
cross cutting cleavages as we talk
about them in modern political science.
The notion here is if you're
in a majority on one question,
but you know,
you might be on in a different majority
or in the minority on the next question,
okay?
Then you have both the reason to temper
your own behavior when you're in the
majority and not tyrannized
over the minority.
And if you're in the minority,
you have reasons to accept
your loss this time around.
You know, as, as people always say,
when the team loses the weld series,
there's always next year,
right? There's always next time.
So next time you might be part of some
different coalition and you might be able
to prevail.
So
the best, the best we could have would
be a world with no factions at all.
But that's unrealistic in modern times,
particularly once you have an economic
division of Labor class divisions,
um,
uh,
as Tocqueville would, would, uh,
point out 40 years later.
MMM.
And so then what you need is lots of
factions and that's why Madison argued you
need a big republic,
right?
Because the larger the republic,
the more likely it is that you're going
to have multiple cross cutting cleavages
and then the system,
we sometimes defined democracy
as institutionalized of outcomes.
You don't know,
you don't know what the
majority is going to decide.
Yeah.
We don't know when, uh, if,
let's suppose President Obama nominates,
mmm,
justice would for the court,
we don't know what the outcome will be.
So everybody will participate and lobby
and so on to try and affect the result.
Um, people will talk about
coalitions and, or you know,
a more dramatic case.
I think when George Bush Sr nominated
Clarence Thomas to the supreme court,
it split the African American
community right down the middle, right?
Because there were people who were largely
Democrats who also wanted an African
American justice on the court.
The,
a good example of cross cutting
bases of political affiliation,
right?
And so the,
the Madisonian idea is that
that's actually a good thing.
It's institutionalized uncertainty of
outcomes prevents the terrorizing of some
groups.
Have A,
this at gives everybody an incentive
to remain committed to the process.
And that is what would subsequently
become call the pluralist theory of
democracy associated most famously
in the 20th century with Robert Dahl,
who was on the Yale Faculty for
decades and decades and is still,
it's about to turn actually
95 years old this year. Uh,
and he lives in new haven.
Um,
probably the most famous
democratic theorist, um,
of the second half of the 20th century.
The pluralist theory of democracy belts
on this Madisonian idea that what you
want is institutionalized
uncertainty of outcomes.
That is a byproduct of crosscutting.
Cleavage is multiple cross cutting
cleavages so that witness have reason.
President winters have reason to,
uh,
limit the amount in which they tear
an over losers and present losers have
incentives to remain committed
to the process for the future.
There's always next year you
want people to believe that, uh,
in order to keep them committed.
But that wasn't enough for Madison.
No, that was the basis of his
argument for an extended a union.
Um,
but it wasn't enough for Madison.
He was worried that the
institutional structure,
just as Tocqueville articulated it,
um,
in the 19th century,
that the institutional structure
could facilitate tyranny.
Okay.
He says the greatest security against
the gradual concentration of the several
powers in the same department consists
in giving to those who administer each of
the departments,
each department,
the necessary constitutional means and
personal motives to resist encroachments
of others.
The provision for defense must in this,
as in all other cases,
be commensurate to the danger of the task.
Ambition must be made
to counteract ambition.
Maybe the most famous
line Madison ever wrote,
ambition must be made
to counteract ambition.
The interest of the man must be connected
with the constitutional rights of the
place.
It may be a reflection of human nature
that such devices should be necessary to
control the abuses of
government. Now, the famous line,
if men were angels,
whoops,
no government would be necessary.
If angels were to govern men,
neither external nor internal controls
on government would be necessary in
framing a government, which is to
be administered by men over men.
The great different the lies in this,
you must first enable the government to
control the governed and next oblige it
to control itself.
A dependence on the people is no doubt
the primary control of the government,
but experience has taught mankind the
next set and the necessity of auxiliary
precautions.
So
your basic
guarantor is the,
the,
mmm
crosscutting cleavages among the
people and extended republic.
But that's not enough because,
and this is really a,
a view that most famously associated
with the 19th century liberal British
thing.
Lord Acton,
when he said power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely.
The notion is that you really
have to divide up power.
You have to have an institutional scheme.
That's is an auxiliary precautions,
an institutional scheme which causes
people in the different branches of
government to check one another.
And so we'd get what Madison called a
nonorganic or republic rather than a
democracy. Uh, and in that sense,
Madison is a critic of democracy,
just like Tocqueville, uh,
beef, uh, and just like Plato,
they wanted to say that pure democracy
leads to tyranny and we have to check it
with an institutional scheme
that limits what can be done.
And so,
uh,
the American system so
called checks and balances,
which you also learned about
in high school civics courses,
structures, the constitutional
system that they created.
And it is,
this is something that you can tell
from the passage from Tocqueville that I
read you,
that Tocqueville didn't fully understand
or appreciate because he thought that
every branch of the government
was ultimately controlled
by the majority and the
designers of the constitution
intended rather, um,
to have them at least controlled in
different ways by majority opinion.
But more importantly to set up a scheme
in which they would control one another.
Ambition would be made
to counteract ambition.
And so you would you, we've all
been reading in the newspapers, uh,
this weekend at the moment
of their retirement of,
of Justice John Paul
Stevens, uh, that he was,
he was one of the people,
for instance,
who checked the expansion of
executive power I after nine 11.
And the harm done case by saying it
was unconstitutional to use military
tribunals to try,
uh,
the Guantanamo Bay
detainees
from the point of view of Madison.
This specific issue is
not what's important here,
but rather that what we saw after nine 11,
which is a big expansion
of executive power.
Okay.
Right.
And then you see an assertion of power
by different branch to say to the
executive, no, you can't do that.
And so our limiting of executive power
in this case by the judicial branch,
and so what you have
in the American scheme,
the American constitutional scheme
is a large number of Vito points.
First of all,
we have the bill of rights.
The bill of rights was enacted
after the constitution,
but only when undertakings had been made,
uh,
than it would be enacted in most of the
state legislatures. So it was
basically, even though it came,
there was an informal agreement by the
time the constitution was adopted that
they would be a bill of rights.
That what became the first 10 amendments
that would limit the power of the
central government.
And so we have a bill of rights and then
we have super majority requirements,
most obviously to change the constitution.
Huge,
super majority requirements,
right? To amend the constitution.
It's very difficult.
You need two thirds in both houses of
Congress and then three quarters of the
states.
Some of your parents were around at
the last serious effort to amend the
constitution, namely the era,
the equal rights amendment,
which failed to get that,
to pass that threshold very hard.
But then we have other super
majority requirements, uh,
the filibuster rule in the Senate,
which we may see come into play and
Supreme Court confirmation hearings.
That's not in the constitution, but
it's, it's a super majority requirement.
Uh, nonetheless that we've embedded
in our institutional scheme.
Anytime you add super
majority requirements,
okay.
Anytime you add super
majority requirement,
you make it harder for the
current majority to work.
It's well separation of
powers already alluded to,
uh,
the court versus the executive,
the legislature versus the executive.
The notion that ambition of players in
one branch will counteract the ambition
of plas in a different branch.
Greatly debated subject.
Uh,
how effective can the branches really
be to check one another after all,
the court does not have
an army at its disposal.
You know,
if the court had,
mmm,
you guys are young enough to remember the
2000 election when we had a knife edge
result and partisans on both side was
saying that candidate won and it was being
litigated in various ways through the
state courts in Florida and we didn't have
a clear result.
Um,
and finally the Supreme Court in Bush
v Gore ruled in a very controversial
decision.
Okay.
That President Bush was the winner.
Well then candidate Bush was the winner
and Vice President Gore was the loser
and Gore stood on national
television and he said,
I accept the result.
I don't agree with the result,
but I accept the result.
He didn't have to.
You could imagine in many
countries at that point,
the Clinton administration would have
sent the tanks down Pennsylvania Avenue.
What would the court have been able to do?
Nothing.
Right?
It's far from obvious in
Iraq, right? That the,
the loser of the erection is going
to accept the result. So there's,
there's great debate cause the,
the
Madison Madison makes heavy weather in
the federalist papers of the proposition
that just writing something on a parchment
doesn't guarantee that people are
gone except what you,
right.
Okay.
So what does it really mean to say
that there's separation of powers?
Was the court ultimately is dependent
upon people just going along with what it
says? Right. And likewise
with the legislature. Um,
yes. You know, they just, there's
this attempt to separate congress.
Congress votes in theory only Congress
can declare war and Congress has to fund
the military.
Um,
but in practice it's very difficult for
Congress to resist what the executive
branch wants to do on
the all of those things.
And when we look at cases
where the court faces down,
even either the legislature
or the executive branch,
it's usually only in cases where what
they're doing is very popular when they're
doing, you know, when they telling
Nixon to turn over the tapes,
1974, 1973 74, uh,
it's unanimous cord and
it's a popular action.
Um,
if Nixon had been at 95% in
the opinion polls at that time,
it's less clear that the court would have
faced down the executive branch or at
least so some scholars claim.
So how much you really get
separation of powers is,
is a subject that's greatly debated by
political scientists because at the end
of the day,
despite what Madison says,
separation of powers is just something
written on a parchment as Dall puts it in
his critique of Madison in the preface
to democratic theory is most important
book,
which was published in 1956
and it's still in print.
Very few of us can say we wrote a book,
uh,
50 years ago that's still in print,
but there it is, it is still in print.
Um, the all says, the
problem with this famous,
this famous one liner of Madison's is
that there's actually no real mechanism to
ensure that ambition will
counteract ambition. And it's rare.
That is simply that
people accept this scheme.
But what if they didn't?
What if in 1800,
that had not been a turnover of power?
We had a knife Angela section in 1800.
MMM
maybe that would have made America
mmm.
Much more prone to the, the
seizure of power by, um,
those who currently controlled the levers
of power, the military on. So we didn't,
we had it,
the loser gave up in 1800 and we began
to create this culture of democratic
trends,
turnovers where the,
the government loses an
election and gives up power.
Very unusual thing,
but it happens.
So separation of powers,
much debated, and I'm going
to come back to this, um,
much debated as to how effective
and important it really is.
More veto points.
We have bicameralism as you know,
from reading the federalist papers,
the founders were mostly worried about
the power of Congress because it seemed
like it was going to be the most powerful
branch if the executive was weak and
designed to be weaker,
much weaker than it is today.
And so they thought the
thing to do is to divide.
Congress have a by camera
system and legislation has
to be passed in both houses
and have them elected by different rules.
So we have,
um, Senate seats elected
at large in the states,
whereas we have small congressional
districts and therefore we have very
different incentives that the politicians
are going to react to very different
factions overlapping with one another,
uh,
in different ways to get back
to the basic pluralist ideal.
And then finally of course last but by
no means least in terms of veto points,
federalism,
federalism is in another source of
yeah.
Vito points in what can actually happen.
Thank in your,
in the last few years of
debates about gay marriage,
you know,
we have marital law is State Law.
MMM.
And for a long time there has been,
okay.
A federal law which says if
you get married in one state,
the marriage will be recognized
and in every other state.
So if people move and then later
on they get divorced to one dies.
It doesn't matter what state you were in
for the purposes of the divorce or full
probate law,
you are still going to be governed by it.
Just a sort of utilitarian
efficiency thing. Yeah.
Every state can have
differences in it's marital law.
But California has got a recognized
Connecticut's marriages as valid.
Then along comes a socially
divisive issue like gay marriage.
Okay.
And unsurprisingly,
some states,
one to enact gay marriage and some don't.
But then this federal requirement that
all states recognize one another's
marriages suddenly becomes
ideologically charged, right?
Whereas it was presented as just
a utilitarian, efficient thing.
Now it becomes ideologically charged
because if the state of Massachusetts
recognizes gay marriage,
then in implicitly means that the state
of Georgia has to recognize it as well.
So you'd get an upsurge
of political activism.
And finally the defense of Marriage Act
in Congress to preserve the rights of
the states
to reject or accept,
mmm.
Gay Marriage.
And so that's an example of the
veto power of states in play,
uh, that, that, uh,
rears its head in a setting like that.
And so what you have in
the U S is not a democracy,
certainly not a pure democracy.
You rather have what they design was
what they referred to as a non tyrannical
republic. They thought that
that was the best they could do.
They had misgivings about a lot of it,
but they thought that
this was the only way.
Okay.
They could create the Union
and head off civil war.
Of course, they did set off
set. We had civil war. Anyway,
a subject I'll come back to on Wednesday,
but we created this hybrid between a
what and and non tyrannical republic,
if you like,
and democratic system and many of our
arguments about contemporary democracy are
really arguments about how much we should
preserve this hybrid and how much we
should have a thoroughgoing
democratic system.
And I'll take that up on Wednesday.